salut les gars, je suis super excité de vous
parler d'une opportunité incroyable que nous avons
ici pour vous maintenant c'est en fait la
chance d'une vie pour tous
les créateurs de costumes potentiels
Yahoo style s'est associé à l'un
des meilleurs réalisateurs du cinéma Luke  meilleure
chanson maintenant, vous le connaissez peut-être dans des films
comme Lucy le cinquième élément et aussi
mon préféré le professionnel maintenant,
il demande aux artistes et designers en herbe
de créer un costume pour son
nouveau film valériane et d'avoir une chance de
voir leur travail prendre vie sur le  grand
écran ici pour tout vous dire c'est
l'homme lui-même Luke c'est tout salut Josie
merci beaucoup mon nouveau film s'appelle
valériane et la cité des mille
planètes donc énorme aventure pour moi le
plus grand défi de ma vie je ne veux pas
pour le faire seul je veux que vous fassiez
partie de cette grande expérience valériane
est un film d'aventure épique de science-fiction qui
se déroule hors de l'espace sur une
station spatiale appelée alpha un millier d'espèces
qui y vivent extraterrestres  créatures êtres
humains vivant ensemble en paix en
harmonie à un certain moment du film
ils assistent à une fête sorte de
parti politique beaucoup de dignitaires militaires
extraterrestres bien sûr mais qu'est-ce qu'ils
portent et voici Olivier
créateur de costumes d'inhumation je travaille avec ce gars
depuis presque  200 ans 20 ans
olivia va vous donner plus de détails à ce sujet,
vous pouvez sélectionner jusqu'à 20
dessins chacun sera transformé en un
vrai costume qu'un acteur sera dans
le film c'est un cocktail alors
supposons que vous êtes  all fr Humana Reed
sera quelque part habiller le monde d'
al-arian tout va bien alors laissez
aller votre imagination wow la principale chose dont vous
devez vous souvenir est que vous consommerez
sera bien par un être humain vous
devez garder de la place pour la tête  les bras sur
les jambes nous devons garder la taille
limitée à 2 mètres à 3 mètres aussi si
vous choisissez vous pouvez nous envoyer des
échantillons de photos des échantillons des échantillons textuels
la vision de Luc Besson est très chauve
sans imagination donc  ne vous limitez pas
à la bonne chance à tout le monde bonne chance